[Musica]
Forse mentre facevo questi piccoli passi
per aggiungere questo tappeto rosso
avrete notato un particolare di me
Magari ho il colore dell'abito del
vostro colore preferito o magari vi
piacciono le mie scarpe o il taglio dei
miei capelli non so se c'è qualcuno
qualcuna di voi che invece ha pensato
questa persona ha una
disabilità Secondo me no perché quella
che io vivo è una disabilità invisibile
ovvero una condizione che vivo che sento
quotidianamente io dall'interno Ma che
non manifesta sintomi all'esterno da me
fuori dal mio corpo quindi magari
vedendomi camminare lungo la strada o
incontrandomi mille posti del mondo
nessuno penserebbe di me è una persona
con una
disabilità spesso mi sveglio la mattina
con le gambe gonfie o con le caviglie
gonfie a causa di un linfedema e faccio
una fatica tremenda ad alzarmi dal letto
e faccio anche fatica magari a spiegare
la mia condizione alle persone della mia
sfera Vitale al lavoro nella mia vita
relazionale nella mia famiglia con le
persone
vicine a volte mi capita che sono ad una
cena sono al tavolo con tantissime
persone sono in un momento molto
tranquillo ad un certo punto sento dei
sintomi strani e Sento ansia senso di
soffocamento panico nebbia cognitiva
ovvero una specie di condizione nella
quale non so più chi sono effettivamente
avverto come il mio corpo staccato da me
allora all'improvviso prendo esco dal
ristorante e magari non ho il tempo di
dire alle persone che stanno al tavolo
con me che appunto mi sto sentendo male
non c'è tempo di contestualizzare di
spiegare tante volte mi è successo di
sentire le persone al tavolo dire Ma che
cos'ha Quella ragazza è strana è
esagerata per un mal di testa per un
giramento di
Capo soprattutto se sei una persona
socializzata donna Allora stai
esagerando Allora il tuo dolore può
essere banalizzato e invece no in quel
momento io non ho forza neanche di
capire chi io sia E che cosa ci faccio
in questo
mondo nel mio caso specifico queste
condizioni e questi disturbi che vi sto
raccontando sono causa conseguenza anzi
di un cancro che ho vissuto Quando avevo
anni non sono l'unica a vivere una
condizione di questo genere ci sono
tantissime persone in Italia centinaia e
centinaia che vivono disabilità
invisibili Magari hanno patologie
mentali hanno vulvo di neuropatia del
pudendo fibromialgia Hanno tantissime
patologie rare e nessuno se ne
accorge a volte neanche
noi avere un cancro in un'età
considerata giovane Dove si pensa a
tutto tranne che ad affrontare un
percorso di questo genere quasi che ci
rende
supereroi è veramente importante perché
è un momento dove tutto si ferma e dove
bisogna ridisegnare la propria storia
personale e anche i contorni del proprio
ruolo all'interno di quella che è la
collettività la
società non so voi ma io sono sempre
cresciuta in un contesto all'interno del
quale la malattia viene vista come
qualcosa che dall'esterno arriva
all'improvviso senza preavviso e ci
coglie impreparati ci coglie come
persone che in un qualche modo non sono
pronte ad affrontarla come se Fos inermi
fragili Ecco il paradigma della malattia
dalla quale bisogna rifuggire dalla
quale bisogna scappare perché non siamo
in grado di affrontarla può cambiare e
può diventare la malattia è qualcosa di
interno al nostro corpo è come se fosse
già dentro di
noi la malattia fa parte del patto
universale Pensateci quando noi nasciamo
il patto con l'universo è che la vita
corrisponde all morte Lo scopriamo
sempre troppo tardi lo scopriamo quando
non abbiamo le forze di comprenderlo per
davvero quando siamo grandi quando
abbiamo tante
sovrastrutture decostruire questo
concetto ci aiuta a vivere la malattia
come qualcosa di
interno qualcosa che fa parte appunto
del passaggio umano su questa
Terra vedete tutto questo passa
attraverso il linguaggio noi possiamo
attraverso il linguaggio contornare le
cose descriverle dare loro un senso e
allora se possiamo utilizzare il
linguaggio e siamo gli unici nel mondo
che possono farlo possiamo cambiare
questi paradigmi possiamo rendere la
vulnerabilità qualcosa di accettabile di
condivisibile div
vivibile Pensateci a quante volte la
vulnerabilità e la
fragilità rende le persone ai margini le
porta fuori al di là le porta lontano
invece bisogna abbracciarla la
vulnerabilità Bisognerebbe prendersene
cura molto spesso sento il termine
bellico accostato alla
malattia Io penso che questo termine
bellico debba essere appunto debellato
perché la vita e la malattia non è
appunto una guerra non è un duello
perché il duello spac
il nostro vissuto e la nostra vita in
due parti in una vittoria ed in una
sconfitta ma non è così La vita e non è
così la malattia una persona che non è
più in questa terra a causa di una
patologia oncologica non è perché non ha
avuto le forze non ha avuto le risorse
necessarie non è stato bravo o brava
Semplicemente così vanno le cose
semplicemente Ci sono casi che non hanno
esiti
felici questo toglie responsabilità alla
persona che la vive fa vivere
sicuramente quel portato di malattia
quindi di disabilità di disabilità
invisibile un po' più vivibile e un po'
più
visibile Purtroppo questi nostri
linguaggi
appunto rendono la persona che vive la
condizioni di malattia disabilità e
disabilità invisibile una persona
appunto fragile rotta e
vulnerabile
quindi una persona che in un qualche
modo è discriminata quante volte se
sentiamo questa parola quotidianamente
perché ci sono tantissime persone che ne
parlano oggi delle discriminazioni e
Finalmente direi la discriminazione è
qualcosa che non dovrebbe esistere
perché a causa di una condizione
personale o sociale Allora quella
persona non ha gli stessi diritti o non
vive una pari condizione rispetto agli
altri che non vivono appunto quelle
condizioni
lì immaginatemi entrare in una
concessionaria e scegliere un auto
finalmente sono grande e voglio essere
indipendente dalla mia
famiglia Ora immaginatemi parlare con
una persona che lavora in banca e
immaginate che questa persona da un
momento all'altro Mi dica lei non può
ottenere una copertura assicurativa sul
finanziamento che ci ha richiesto perché
ha avuto il
cancro ora immaginate un milione di
persone in una piazza
sono tantissime quasi che lo sguardo non
arriva a vederle tutte oggi Un milione
di persone in Italia sono guarite da una
patologia oncologica Eppure questo
milione di persone è discriminato e la
maggior parte delle volte neanche lo
sa abbiamo paura della discriminazione
abbiamo paura di farci vedere dagli
altri come persone che stanno ai margini
che sono considerate minori perché
appunto non con le stesse condizioni
degli altri
eppure non è capitato soltanto a me è
capitato alla mamma di un mio amico che
doveva ristrutturare casa non le
concedevano un prestito se non fosse
stato per l'aiuto della propria
famiglia non penso che sia una
condizione di uguaglianza quella che una
coppia non ha potuto adottare e un'altra
non ha potuto ricevere la non ha potuto
continuare la pratica di affido perché
nel primo caso il potenziale padre aveva
avuto un tumore ai testicoli mentre
nell'altro caso le lei la potenziale
mamma aveva avuto un'altra patologia
oncologica non trovo che sia una
condizione di uguaglianza quella di una
persona che viene demion di una persona
che ha bisogno di Feri al lavoro per
fare le visite le visite di followup
esami non procrastinabili e magari devo
utilizzare i giorni delle ferie del
Riposo che appunto sono delle ferie e
del
riposo Ci sono persone che non possono
realizzare i propri sogni ma questo è il
nostro tempo Questa è la nostra vita se
noi siamo qua è per miracolo della
scienza è perché abbiamo fatto
prevenzione è perché ci sono stati dei
tasselli che si sono infilati bene e ci
hanno permesso di
vivere non possiamo essere magari
persone guarite per la medicina e non
guarite per le istituzioni per la
società non guardateci così non
guardiamoci
così oggi nel 2023 si sta muovendo
qualcosa perché a livello i Ale
ovviamente c'è un testo unificato di
legge che stiamo attendendo da tanto
tempo che permetterebbe alle persone di
non dover dichiarare di aver avuto la
patologia
oncologica Io penso
che siccome non sono l'unica che vive
tutto questo ma tutto questo è
importante rivalutarlo perché si rifà
non soltanto nella sfera personale
relazionale si rifà anche tanto sulla
società noi possiamo fare tante cose
possiamo sicuramente ridisegnare quelli
che sono i contorni appunto della
vulnerabilità i contorni
dell'uguaglianza
concetto
importantissimo c'è una frase di brust
che io mi sono segnata perché non ne
voglio veramente sbagliare mezza parola
che dice
così la ferita
dell'amore ci ci consente l'accesso a
quell'uscita fuori di se stessi a quella
via di comunicazione privata che è
destinata a immettersi nella grande
strada dove passa ciò che ci è dato
conoscere solo quando cominciamo a
soffrire la vita degli
altri forse neanche io e forse neanche
voi prima di incontrare un momento
delicato della propria vita faceva caso
alla vita gli altri ma guardiamoci siamo
tanti siamo
tante non Dobbiamo considerare la vita
degli altri soltanto quando noi
riusciamo a percepirla non dobbiamo
capire la sofferenza degli altri
soltanto quando la proviamo noi possiamo
fare molto di più possiamo smettere di
giustificare le
discriminazioni possiamo smettere di non
validare il dolore degli altri Se una
persona ci dice che sta male che sta
poco bene sta male non sta poco
bene possiamo creare delle politiche
attive possiamo far parte di
associazioni possiamo informare
divulgare ma soprattutto io credo che
possiamo iniziare da molto più vicino
possiamo iniziare dai nostri nuclei
familiari nuclei personali amicali
possiamo iniziare da noi stessi a
vederci e a validar per quello che siamo
siamo storie siamo pezzi fondamentali di
questo mondo senza di noi questo mondo
sarebbe totalmente diverso e tutto
questo ha importanza e le voci stanno
arrivando nelle sedi giuste perché
abbiamo iniziato a parlare a raccontarlo
a non tenerlo nella nostra stanza chiuso
a
chiave c'è un'immagine stupenda e e una
domanda correlata a questa immagine può
davvero una luce illuminare il mondo me
lo sono chiesta tante volte e la
risposta è che sì sì sicuramente una
luce può illuminare il mondo ma ognuno
di noi
ognuna di noi è una luce e tutti e tutte
noi siamo indispensabili affinché questa
luce effettivamente possa illuminare il
mondo Quindi quello che vi chiedo è
questo quello che ci chiedo è
questo siamo luce vuol dire parlare di
noi non lasciare andare ma riversarlo
verso l'esterno Perché la nostra storia
e la nostra vita non è soltanto la
nostra storia e la nostra vita ma è la
storia della collettività dell'umanità e
del mondo
Grazie